a esta iglesia es uno de los muchos
edificios que han sido construidos en
los últimos años en en cagua un barrio
de erbil entre 2014 y 2017 buen número
de cristianos llegaron hasta aquí
huyendo de la persecución del grupo
estado islámico tuvieron que organizarse
y sobre todo construir el barrio
luego del éxodo a cogimos a todos los
desplazados de mosúl de bar tela y de
otras provincias esta iglesia la
construimos rápidamente nuestros curas y
la población contribuyeron a financiar a
la milicia la mayoría de campos de
refugiados cerraron tras la derrota de
los yihadistas pero muchos cristianos se
quedaron es el caso de esta pareja
originaria de caracol viven en un
pequeño apartamento que les prestó
gratuitamente una familia de agua marrón
ya no regresamos porque la situación en
cuanto a seguridad no es bueno nuestra
casa fue incendiada no hay trabajo y no
tenemos medios suficientes para vivir
allá aquí al menos hay libertad hay
trabajo es mejor que en caracollo hace
unos años en cada agua no era más que un
pueblo pero con la sucesión de crisis
los cristianos vinieron a refugiarse
aquí esta población terminó
convirtiéndose en un barrio de erbil una
especie de gueto christi
tras la caída de sadam husein en 2003 la
ola de violencia entre comunidades
incendió el país el atentado a la
catedral de bagdad en 2010 quedó marcado
en la memoria este ataque reivindicado
por al qaeda dejó más de 68 muertos
entre ellos el hijo de artemis esta
funcionaria ya jubilada vive desde
entonces en erbil junto con su hermana
estábamos en shock nunca pensamos que la
opresión tomaría semejante forma es algo
que va más allá del entendimiento aun
para los musulmanes
el esquema de annie por ese entonces
muchos cristianos se fueron de irak
otros decidieron mudarse a erbil un mes
en esa época los cristianos perseguidos
tuvieron la posibilidad de refugiarse en
erbil incluso los funcionarios podían
pedir su traslado había facilidades para
venir desde las provincias de kurdistán
en 20 años los cristianos de irak
pasaron de ser un millón y medio a menos
de 400 mil quienes decidieron quedarse
esperan que la visita del papa- lleve a
que las autoridades trabajen a favor de
su comunidad